[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKUR KOTWAL: Good
afternoon, everybody.
How's everyone doing?
Yeah?
Well, I hope you're having a
good time here at Cloud Next.
My name is Ankur Kotwal,
and I'm a developer advocate
on the Google Maps API team.
Today I want to talk
to you about how
you can build with the Google
Maps APIs for your use cases,
for your industries, and how the
Google Maps APIs fit together
to provide great solutions.
But before we get too
far down that line,
I actually want to take a
quick trip down memory lane.
The Google Maps APIs is
one of the first APIs
that Google ever launched.
And it happened actually
a bit over 11 years ago.
That's when we first
launched the APIs.
And the consumer product, the
actual Google Maps website,
hadn't launched much
earlier than that.
When we launched the website
itself, the consumer product,
it was the first time that we
were transitioning paper maps
to digital maps.
Now, if you think
back 11-12 years ago,
it's not that long ago.
But this idea today of us using
paper maps to get anywhere
seems quite archaic.
We've moved.
Our behaviors have changed
substantially since then,
where you'd pull up this
big folding paper map,
try and find your current
location in some index, which
would give you a page number
maybe or a grid number.
You'd look it up.
And then if you actually
had to go somewhere,
then you had to find
your destination
and you had to
route it yourself.
Today, you would pretty
much never do that.
So as we started to build
our Google Maps apps,
we started with the base map.
And we started to then add
satellite imagery as well,
make that available.
Suddenly we were able to see
the real world from space,
effectively, what you
can see from space.
We added some
elevation and terrain.
But it was really when
smartphones came along
that we hit this inflection
point of usability.
Suddenly we had the
world in our pocket.
We had maps in our pockets.
We were able to harness the
power of these smartphones
to include things
like 3D buildings.
We were actually able
to direct people.
They no longer
needed to do things
themselves to get places.
And of course, places, I
used that word just now.
We were able to
now start to bring
semantic meaning to where you
are or where you were going.
You didn't have to think about
your destination as an address.
And that's immensely powerful,
and I'll show you why.
And then the world we
live in today, we're
very demanding of
our mapping products.
We expect that when
we're routing somewhere,
when we're heading
to work, let's
say, that if there is
an incident on the road,
if there are some roadworks, if
there's an accident, if there's
a slowdown that we expect our
apps will actually route us
around there.
Think about doing that
in the paper days.
You'd just kind
of try and route,
follow the route
that you'd set out,
and hope that you
made it on time,
let alone try to
dynamically route yourself
around any issues
that you came across.
And we also have
things like transit.
We're starting to surface
information about foot traffic
as well.
But the cool thing is this was
our story for the consumer app.
We've actually followed the
same story for our APIs.
Because we believe
that developers
are key to this story, that
we're not the only ones
that can build
magical experiences
with this kind of information.
And it's the Google Maps
APIs that are powering apps
with this kind of information.
And when you look at
our suite of APIs,
you can then start to see that
those APIs can combine together
to address some really
interesting use cases.
Fairly straightforward
use cases,
like store locators,
which you might think
is like a pin on a map.
But store locators can be
so much more than that.
Real estate agencies
use store locators
or a version of store
locators, to show their users
what their dream homes
are going to look like,
what area they're going to
be, how close the beach is.
Put on satellite imagery
for a beach house
and you've sold the
place very quickly.
And consider things
like ride-sharing today,
or ride-hailing.
In the old days, we would stand
on the side of the street,
stick out a hand, hope that
a taxi or a cab went past
and was available.
And we would then be on our way.
Today, we pull
out a phone, we're
able to then say, hey,
find me my closest taxi.
It will find a driver for you.
But if you think about the
other side of the experience,
where you actually tell
it your destination,
you don't have to type in
a full address anymore.
You don't have to swipe
your map to get there.
You type in a few characters,
and it autocompletes
what your destination is.
These apps are smart
enough to remember
what your most popular
destinations are,
where you came from, and
where you're going to.
And the Maps APIs are enabling
this great user experience.
They're enabling this transition
or this transformation
in user behaviors.
So look at those
use cases, and we
start to see these
industries that these use
cases can have impact and
have positive impact on.
We just talked about
transportation and logistics.
Think about insurance.
We're able to see the
kinds of foot traffic
that you get in certain areas.
So if you park your car out
on the streets in a busy area,
that insurance premium
could be higher
than if you happen to have
a garage in the same area.
And these industries,
new industries,
are sprouting up all the time.
If I had given this
talk a year ago,
I would not have included
gaming on this slide.
Not because gaming
is a new industry,
but in the last nine months we
have seen Pokemon Go explode.
And it's because that team,
that brilliant team at Niantic,
were able to work
out how to make
location-based gaming
or real-world gaming
relevant to all these users.
And one of the data
sources that they used
was our Google Maps APIs.
So, you can see that these APIs
are really powering big things.
Which brings me
to today's topic,
which is the Maps API layers.
I'm going to present to you
four layers for developing
on the Google Maps APIs.
And the way I'm going
to present this to you
is talk to you about
use cases and industries
that we're able to address
with each of these.
Now think of this
stack as a developers
stack, where you
start at the top.
There's minimal code
required from your side.
But as we go further
down the stack,
we get increased
customizability and control
of how we present
our experience.
So let's start with delegation.
And delegation really is
about saying, you know what.
I believe I need some sort of
mapping, some sort of location
intelligence in my app.
But I'm going to let somebody
else handle it for me.
I'm going to let Google
handle it for me.
For whatever reason, it could
be for development constraint
reasons, or it might
just not be a core piece
of functionality in your app.
And on Android, we
have this mechanism
called Intents, where you
can from one app intent out
to another app.
And you can provide
some additional context
so that it can initialize
that other app to whatever it
is that you're looking for.
So if you look at
these intents here,
the first thing we're doing is
loading a map of San Francisco.
So this is where,
in your app, you
might want to send your users.
You want to provide them a
map of some sort, centered
around San Francisco.
And in three lines of
code, you can say, hey,
give me that latitude-longitude
which is line one.
We create that URI, create an
intent passing that URI in.
And then we set this
package that says,
hey, send it off to
Maps, and then start
activity, four lines of code.
We can also do it for
things like actual searches.
So maybe we don't know
the actual destination
we want to go and we're
just doing some discovery.
So here we put in the lat
long that we talked about
at the start.
But we also added a
query for restaurants.
We can kick off navigation.
Because many apps kind
of want to point users
to their destination, but
not necessarily control
that navigation experience.
We can do that.
And here we're going to
Taronga Zoo in Australia.
We can even fire up Street View.
Now we've talked
about Android here.
But you can achieve
the same thing on iOS.
And on iOS, the comparable
feature is called URL Scheme.
So if you look at
the demo on the left,
we're just hitting launch.
And it's actually
firing up the browser.
Now what I'm going to
show you is the iOS code
to achieve this.
And the reason that
there's more code on iOS,
is one, it's Objective-C. So
it's a little bit more verbose.
But two, that first if
condition that block,
is checking whether the user has
the Google Maps app installed.
If it does, it's
going to use it.
So on Android, you can
be fairly confident
that users are going
to have Google Maps.
On iOS it's sort of a
personal preference.
Some users will have it.
Many users will have it.
Some users won't.
And so a piece of code like
this, in the first if block,
we're able to check,
hey, do you have the app.
If so, fire up Google Maps.
If not, just fall
back to the browser,
and we're able to
accomplish the same things.
So that's simple.
That's that first
layer of delegation,
we're not really doing
anything inside of our apps.
We're letting Google
handle it for us.
Layer two of this
stack is incorporation,
where we want to put a little
bit of mapping functionality
in, but again, it's fairly
light functionality.
We just want a simple map.
And here on a website, you
could use the Static Maps API.
The cool thing about
the Static Maps API
is it's just a URL
that you pass in.
And you put in the
parameters that you need.
So we've said the center
is a particular location.
We specify the zoom levels.
We can even specify a
resolution in our API key.
And this will return
back us an image.
So the nice thing about this is
there's no JavaScript involved.
You just put an image tag
with this URL around it,
and you're away.
We give you some
customization options as well.
So as you can see from
the three screenshots,
we've applied a custom style
on the very left-hand side.
It's a monochrome style.
On the second slide, we've
used satellite imagery.
And on the third one,
we've actually drawn a line
that there's a blue line
in the middle that's
navigating you from--
I think in this case,
it's my hotel room
to my office in Mountain View.
But if you want to go
beyond Static Maps,
if you want to make
it interactive,
if you don't want just a
picture, we have the Embed API.
And that allows you to
embed a map onto your site.
It'll put it in a nice
little frame there,
and you're doing it by
specifying an I-frame.
And you can do things like,
again, provide directions
or even do street view.
So we're just starting to
touch the surface of some
of the mapping
functionality we can do.
Now for the next piece
of incorporation,
I'm going to look at
a specific use case.
And that's location sharing.
Now it may not be
obvious to everybody,
but location sharing is actually
something we do very often.
And it's useful in
many, many contexts.
It might be as simple as just
letting your family member know
that you're running
late, because you're
stuck in traffic.
You might location share,
I'm stuck in traffic.
I'm here.
It could be that you're saying
I need to get somewhere.
So going back to our
ride-sharing application
where we're trying to
find a taxi for us,
we usually share
our current location
so we can get picked up there.
Now that might seem
like a lot of work.
But we've tried to make
it really, really easy;
easy for you as developers
and easy for your users.
And there's two things I'm
going to talk about here.
The first one is
the Place Picker.
And the Place Picker
is a UI widget
that you can just
drop into your apps
and it provides this
fantastic user experience.
I'm going to kick
off the animation.
But you have a
map in the middle.
You can drag it around,
you can drop it on a pin.
And then below that
map, we actually
have a list of locations.
So in case you don't want
to interact with the map,
you can just pull up
the list of locations
and identify which
place you're at.
There is also a
search box at the top,
so you can type in which
location you're at.
But the nice thing is we
provide an out-of-the-box user
experience that's very familiar
to users and is powered
by the Google Maps APIs.
So you know it's going to be
accurate and you can trust it.
It's an easy way to have your
users share their location.
Because they can just
pick what's there.
The nice thing is it
requires very little code.
So on Android, we have
two parts to this code.
The first part is we're going
to start off the Place Picker
activity.
We're going to say, hey,
go ahead and show the Place
Picker.
We create one of these Place
Picker intent builders.
And then we call this method
startActivityForResult.
And the reason we
call that method
is because we want to know when
the user has finished selecting
a place that that
process has finished
and it can pass us the result.
So once the user goes and
interacts with this widget,
we get a call back.
We just confirm that we've
come back because of the Place
Picker, and then
we get the place
that the user selected,
couldn't be easier.
And suddenly location
sharing, which can
be a hugely complex affair--
can you imagine trying to
code an experience like this
dropping a map in,
having scrollable lists,
using GPS or Wi-Fi to
actually populate those lists
in a meaningful way?
It's not necessarily
trivial code.
But we've trivialized it by
providing this out-of-the-box
widget.
And we have parity
on iOS as well.
So on iOS, again, it's a
similar amount of code.
We're going to instantiate
a GMSPlacePickerConfig.
We're going to go
ahead and kick it off,
so it displays the Place Picker.
And when we get the
call back, we're
just going to pull that place.
You see that last
if condition there.
We're just going to pull
the place out of it.
And in this case, we're
getting the place names.
That's it.
That's how easy it
is to share location.
Another example where our
ride-sharing application
might be useful is
something autocomplete.
So if you think
about ride-sharing,
when we want to get picked up,
we always have a place to go.
So if you think about
your ride-sharing app,
you look up at your destination.
You know, I'm not a fan of the
keyboard on mobile devices.
So I don't like to type a lot.
It's not easy to do.
It's easy to make
typos, and so on.
Autocomplete here is
powered by the same magic
that powers Google
search and Google Maps
in terms of its recognizing
what your intent is
with few characters.
So an autocomplete widget
makes a lot of sense
whenever you need
to ask the user
for an address of any sort.
They can look by name.
They can look by its address.
If they really want
to, they could probably
look by latitude-longitude
as well.
But really, humans
don't work in that way.
Anyways, on iOS, having
an autocomplete widget
the amount of code is
similar to the Place Picker.
We are creating one of these
autocomplete view controllers.
We're firing it off.
We get a callback at the
bottom there with the place
that the user selected.
And we're able to
pull the name out.
On Android, again the
code looks very similar.
We have an intent for
the place autocomplete.
We go ahead and call
startActivityForResult,
and we get the result back.
So location sharing becomes
simple, yet very refined
as a user experience.
So that's some examples
of incorporation.
But I know most of the
developers I work with,
are like, I really
want to go deeper.
I want to be able to
write some code myself
and produce some magic.
And that's really what
integration, layer three,
is about.
It's about saying,
hey, you know what?
This Maps API, I want to use it.
I want the data from it.
I want to customize it.
I want to really make it my own.
I want to personalize it.
And the use case where this
becomes immensely useful
is when you want
to visualize a map.
So let me show you this
particular demo here.
Well, it's a screenshot.
So Google I/O is our other
large conference for developers,
and we have that annually.
And in 2016, Google
I/O for the first time
was actually held at our
campus in Mountain View.
Now Mountain View is actually
quite far from the main San
Francisco city.
And we knew that there
would be a lot of people
that would be traveling
from all over the world
to attend this conference.
So what we did is that
we organized buses
to pick up these attendees
from various hotels
and various parts of
San Francisco city,
and actually all
around the Bay Area.
And these buses would
then take these attendees
to the conference and back.
But we thought what
would be great is
if we could show a demonstration
of our Google Maps APIs,
and display on a
dashboard our bus tracker.
So we built a bus tracker.
And if you look at
this, this layer 3
of integration, what
we're doing here
is that we've grabbed the
usual standard JS Maps API v3,
but we've custom styled it.
We've put custom
markers on there
to represent buses
and represent hotels.
We're using polygons to draw the
path that the buses are taking.
And then we have some just
standard HTML elements
that sit on top that tell you
where these buses are going,
which stops, which hotels
it's going to be stopping at.
But we also added
time estimates.
So if you look at the top of
the boxes, it says leaving in,
next in, and then on
the left-hand side
it tells you time estimates
of how long it's going
to take to get to those spots.
And we're using
the Directions API
to get those time estimates.
But I'll talk about the
Directions API a little bit
later.
But here is an example
of integration,
where we've really changed
the visualization of how
these maps are.
Now if you're interested
in an example like this,
we actually open sourced this
only a couple of weeks ago.
So if you go to
github.com/googlemaps,
and look for transport tracker,
you can see the full source
code for this, and use that
for your purposes as well.
Now we've had custom
styling on maps
for the web version, for the
JS API, for a number of years.
And one of the biggest requests
that we've had from developers
is when is it coming
to Android and iOS.
So it was only a
couple of months
ago that we were thrilled
to be able to launch Custom
Styling for Android and iOS.
And as you can see from the
animated screenshot here,
it works exactly
as you'd expect.
You can change the
style at runtime.
And you don't need to tear the
map down and bring it back up.
You just call setStyle, and
it goes ahead and applies it.
So examples of where
this could be useful
is if you're building a fitness
app, or some sort of a driving
app or navigation app.
If you change the style to
reflect the time of day,
so as it hits evening time we're
able to switch into a night
mode theme and vice versa.
The other really cool
thing about the way
we did custom styling is
that you specify your styles
using JSON file.
And we provided
a styling wizard.
So if you just do a Google
search for Google Maps Styling
Wizard, you'll get to a site
where you can see a map.
And you get a bunch of really
friendly sliders and radio
buttons, where you can get
custom style your map for you.
And it can export a JSON file.
Now the nice thing
about that JSON file,
is it's the same
format whether you
want to use custom
styling on the web,
on Android, or on
iOS, a single file.
And you can either ship
that JSON file on your app
or website, or you
can host it yourself
and then at runtime
dynamically pull down
whatever is your current style.
So, we give you full
flexibility there.
It's not just about
changing colors.
You can actually turn
on or off landmarks.
You can change the
density of labels.
So maybe you don't care for
points of interest in your app,
or you don't need to
show as many roads.
We have sliders that enable
you to turn that up or down.
There's a ton of
flexibility here.
And this is the
type of integration
and that attention to
detail in your apps
that makes your apps
shine and stand out.
So that's how we look
at the map as a whole.
I want to switch gears and talk
a little bit about the camera.
So if you see here, this
is downtown Los Angeles.
We've just got an Android app.
We've focused on
downtown Los Angeles.
And this is a style of map
that you're used to seeing.
In fact, you can see the
heritage of paper maps coming
through here.
But we're on a digital device,
and realistically if you're,
let's say, building
a real estate app,
and you want to show people
what their next dream home could
look like, showing them
some perspective of that map
is a much better user experience
than necessarily showing it
from top down.
Now having this sort
of depth, 3D buildings,
really nicely zoomed
in and having tilt,
that's not necessarily
applicable for every use case.
But you can certainly see having
this sort of rich visualization
in certain types of apps,
like the real estate up,
add a lot of value
to your users.
And pulling this sort of thing
off is incredibly simple.
We have, when you specify a
new camera position on Android,
you have to create one of
these camera position objects.
We have a couple of
methods on there.
So some of these values you
should recognize, things
like target, which is the
latitude and longitude where
you want to focus
on; things like zoom,
which is how far you are.
But then bearing allows you
to turn the camera basically
like a compass to see which
direction you're facing.
And tilt is the thing that comes
in and puts some depth on it.
So it brings that camera really
closer down to the surface,
if you choose.
Just adding those
extra parameters--
and they're just
numeric values--
adds so much more to the
experience of your app.
And the other thing
that I recommend
is that as you change
your camera position,
don't just snap the
camera to place.
Don't move the camera.
Use APIs like this one
called Animate Camera.
And what Animate Camera
does is it works out
the difference between
where the camera is looking
at now compared to
where it needs to be,
and it gracefully
animates the camera there
in a nice smooth flow.
So if your users are going
through, let's say, houses--
we'll continue
with that example--
in a list.
And they're selecting
the next one.
Don't just jump
the camera there.
Move them.
Help them retain that context
of where they're moving to
and where they came from.
On iOS we achieved
the same thing.
Again with iOS in
Objective-C, we
use a GMS camera
position object instead.
We have at the bottom
of those parameters,
you can see bearing.
And instead of tilt on iOS,
it's called viewing angle.
But it means exactly
the same thing.
And as you can see
with this demo here,
we have the same sort of
depth, 3D buildings and so on.
Let's have a look at another
use case, a store locator.
And as I mentioned
earlier, store locators
are much more than
just a marker on a map.
You can make them
very rich and useful,
beyond just one
particular point.
So here's what I did.
I was a little bit
naive, and I searched
for Italian restaurants in Rome.
And I managed to get
quite a few results here.
It shouldn't be a
surprise to anybody.
Just dropping markers where all
these Italian restaurants are,
this is not a great
user experience.
Imagine trying to make
sense of this like, hey,
I'm visiting Rome, and
where should I go and eat?
There's really not much
to be gained from here.
A better way to present
this is with something
that we call marker clustering.
And this is what marker
clustering looks like.
You'll see there's
some clusters there.
And as we zoom in, those
clusters split apart,
and we're able to see
more concentrations
of these markers.
But as we zoom out and
they start to overlap,
we coalesce them.
They group up into
these clusters.
And visually we put
a count on there,
so that your user can see that
this is an important cluster
or not.
So we actually change
the size of the cluster.
We put numbers
around it, and so on.
This is part of an
open source library,
and I'll tell you about
that library in a second.
So you can customize
all of this.
But let me show
you how much code
is required to implement
marker clustering in your apps.
The first thing
you need to do is
tell in your gradle
configuration,
specify that you want to use
the Android Maps utils library.
The second thing you need to
do is look at your data class.
And in our case, our
data class is going
to be our list of restaurants.
So we'll have restaurants
with name and lat long
and whatever else.
Maybe it'll be rating,
cost, any number of things.
But all we need to
do is add this one--
implement this interface,
this one extra method
called getPosition, which just
returns us latitude longitude.
Once we have that done,
we create or instantiate
one of these cluster
managers and we tell our map
that any time the camera changes
or the user clicks on the map
that the map should let the
Cluster Manager know about it.
And that's how when we
interact with the map,
those clusters are coalescing
and forming new ones,
or splitting up.
And then step four, we go ahead
and tell our Cluster Manager
that here are all
our restaurants.
I didn't put the
step five on there.
But the step five is that you
should go ahead and remove
any code that you have, to
add markers onto the map,
or take marketers
out of the map.
Because the Cluster Manager
is going to do that for you.
So in these 10 to
15 lines of code,
we've suddenly implemented
marker clustering,
and we've probably
reduced the amount of code
that we had from
before we started,
so a great user experience
with minimal effort
from a development standpoint.
Instead of clusters, we
can also do heatmaps.
And the heatmap
implementation looks
similar to clusters, where
we generate these heatmaps
depending on zoom levels.
And so as we zoom
in more and more,
you start to see the heatmap
start to split apart.
Or when we zoom out, it
combines into larger ones.
Now I mentioned this was
an open source library.
So if you don't like
my alarming colors,
you can definitely change that.
The API itself allows you
to change that as well.
But it's very easy to do.
Again, the implementation
for this is trivial.
It's the same
library that we use.
We add that interface we
have on our data items.
We then instantiate a
HeatmapTileProvider.
This is the thing that's
going to generate the tiles,
depending on zoom
levels lat longs.
On that step two, I just
want to point out the .data.
That's where we add
our restaurants.
It's just that one line.
It's going to manage it for us.
And then step three,
we add a tile overlay.
And we add it to the map itself.
That's it.
That's the whole code for
the heatmap implementation.
So, when it comes to
doing deep integration,
really look at things
like custom styling.
Personalize your maps.
Look at ways that
you can uniquely
present whatever data it is that
you want to present on a map.
Don't overwhelm your users.
Use the visual metaphors
where possible.
All right.
So we've gotten
to the point where
we've done some integration.
But I've had developers
come and tell me,
but Ankur, I just
want the raw data.
You know what?
I will manage everything.
I want to do it.
I want to control everything.
I want to be the
orchestrator of all of this.
So let's look at an example
in fleet and asset tracking.
Typically with fleet
and asset tracking,
we have a number of vehicles.
We need to do some deliveries.
We need to optimize around that.
So there's a number of APIs
that can really help here.
The first is the Directions API.
Now the Directions
API is a web service.
So you can call it
on any platform.
But we do recommend that you
proxy any of our web services
through a server rather
than consume them directly
on mobile.
And if you want to know
more about why that is,
we had a great talk today called
the development best practices
for Google Maps web services.
It will be up on YouTube
within a day or so.
So please do look that up.
We cover some great
best practices there.
Back to the Directions
API, the great thing
about the Directions
API is one, it
returns you this
nice JSON output.
It tells you
step-by-step directions
on how to get somewhere.
It tells you exact
latitude and longitudes
on how to get your
users to places.
You can specify different travel
modes, whether you're driving--
so in the use case we
were talking about,
the asset tracker, it might be
a driving delivery that we're
doing or it might be cycling.
We could do that too.
But at the bottom there,
you'll see duration.
We can actually give
you travel times
of how long it's
going to take for you
to complete this journey.
And that's immensely powerful,
and very, very useful
for things like
ride-sharing service
that we talked about earlier,
or even any delivery service
that we're going to do.
Now this information is
powered by the same engine
that powers Google Maps
that does navigation, that
provides real-time directions.
We can take this
one step further.
Let's say our business
isn't actually asking
for this information right now.
But they care about the delivery
time at 3:00 AM tomorrow
morning.
We have predictive
travel times for that.
So what we've done
is over time, we've
built this hugely
complicated model of traffic
for all over the world.
We've put it through our
machine-learning algorithms,
and developed new
machine-learned models out
of that.
And we're applying it to
understand traffic conditions,
not just now but
when they'll will
be at various times of the week
at various points in the world.
And of course, if you
know that your vehicle is
going to be on a
road, you should
consider using the Roads API.
Something that actually
surprises a lot of folks,
is when they're told that
the GPS on their phones,
regardless of which
phone you have,
it's actually not that accurate.
There are times-- unless
there's a perfect line of sight,
it's often not very accurate.
It gives you a range of values.
And so even though you're
driving along a straight road,
you could get a GPS
response up here, up here,
down there, across there.
I mean overall you're
going straight,
and you could start
to see that pattern.
But the actual data
that it gives you
is not necessarily straight.
So, I'm going to say
Computer, Enhance.
And we're going to look at
this data that we captured.
So this is a car that was
traveling around this park
and around some buildings.
And what you can see
here is apparently
this car cut across a park,
drove through the park,
and further down actually drove
through a building as well.
Now you can judge my
driving however you want.
But I did not do that.
The Roads API can help
us eliminate these sorts
of problems, noisy GPS.
So what we did is we then
took those exact same points,
put them through the
Roads API, and we ended up
with the green line.
And the Roads API is intelligent
enough to know that, hey look,
I know that this vehicle was on
a road throughout the journey.
I'm going to look at
this data, and I'm
going to interpolate what
is actually happening here.
And so it will snap
those points to the road.
But where you've got curved
roads and things as well,
it will actually
smooth that path out.
It will add new points to that
list of latitude and longitude,
so that when you plot it, it
looks nice and smooth rather
than a jagged polygon.
So the Roads API is
immensely useful.
Let's look at local
discovery as a use case.
Now, in the case
of local discovery,
we just want to see--
we want to learn
about other places
around a particular location.
So I'm from Sydney, Australia.
And so when I visit
San Francisco,
one of the things
that I tend to do
is, hey, which restaurants
should I go and check out,
which bars, you know what
attractions there are.
And one of the APIs where we
provide this information in
is the Places API.
And the Places API
is something that we
provide as a web service,
as well as a native API
on Android and iOS.
And I'm going to cover both.
With the Places API, you
can get lots of information
about a place.
Because if you think about
a latitude and longitude,
it's a point on Earth.
It doesn't make a lot
of sense when you're
in a multi-story building.
In fact, if you're in
a multi-story building
like the Moscone Center
today, you're not even
going to get a GPS location.
Because we don't
have direct line
of sight with the satellites.
We're indoors.
We're also not at a
specific-- we're not just
at a latitude and longitude.
We have to consider height.
And this is where
Places can help.
Places is able to tell
you the difference
between being on floor three of
this building versus floor two.
If you're in a
shopping mall, you
can actually tell whether you're
at a cafe or a hairdresser,
even if they're
somewhat close by.
And the way it does
this is by using
information like latitude and
longitudes, Bluetooth beacons,
Wi-Fi access points, and more,
as well as assisted GPS, which
is triangulating cell phone
tower information as well.
But the great thing is
once you have a place,
it has a ton of
semantic information.
So here's a response that we
get from the JSON request.
I've highlighted a
couple of things.
I'm just going to
talk through those.
The first one is
formatted address.
This is actually a
big challenge to solve
as a developer,
because if you're
a delivery or a logistics
company, especially
a global one, the
way addresses are
formatted in different parts of
the world varies drastically.
Some places have something
called a zip code.
Some places have a post code.
Some use numbers.
Some use letters.
Some put the state before the
zip codes, some put them after.
And getting that right
can mean the difference
between your customer receiving
their package on time,
or either not getting it, or
getting it late or not at all.
And the Places API is able
to format this for you
exactly to the destination.
So we handle that
complexity for you.
We give you the
latitude and longitude.
We also give you the name.
But you're also able to get
some additional metadata.
You can get photos of the place.
You can get information
like ratings of what
the users have said about it.
You can get the
establishment type.
Is it a school?
Is it a library?
Is it a place of worship?
Is it a bar?
So there's tons of
great information.
And if you use the
Places API in your apps,
the thing to remember is
to hold onto this thing
at the bottom called
the Place ID, which
is a unique identifier for
every place in the world.
Because once you
have that Place ID,
you can retrieve any
place details you want.
So it's a great way to
do a local discovery app.
Use the Places API,
do a place search,
and find what types of
places there are around.
And you can filter by
establishment types on the web
servers.
For the Android and iOS API,
we purpose-built the Places API
for specific use cases.
So rather than searching
anywhere in the world,
we wanted to make this
a lot more contextual.
So this is very much about
the places around you.
So on Android, we call
it getCurrentPlace,
or currentPlaceWithCallback
on iOS.
And I'm going to show
you a quick demo.
What happens is when we
use the sensors on a phone,
we give you a list of
places that the user
is likely to be at
and some values.
Now you don't need to see these
values specifically clearly.
Just know that the
likelihood values are
going to be between 0 and 1.
And the closer it is to
1, the more confident
we are that the user
is at that place.
So here's a demo.
We're driving along
the 101, and you'll
see that the list of places that
we're getting back is changing.
They're moving up and down.
And the likelihood
is changing as well,
as we move along that route.
And that's where you can
really use this Places API
to determine where a user is.
And so in that location
sharing example
we talked about earlier, I
showed you the Place Picker.
GetCurrentPlace is the API
that powers the Place Picker.
So if you want to orchestrate
it yourself, you can do that.
It's a bit more work for you.
But it certainly
gives you all the data
and information you need to
make a good user decision.
And we've just talked about a
number of web services today.
They're really, really
useful in different contexts.
We looked at some use cases.
We looked at some solutions.
Now you might find that
you need to use these web
services on different platforms,
and even though web services
can be consumed on
any platform, we've
tried to make that
development easier for you.
We've built a number
of client libraries.
And we've built them for
Go, for Python, for NodeJS,
and for Java.
And they're open sourced.
They're available at
github.com/googlemaps.
And not only do
they make it easier
to consume these web
services in those languages,
but we've also put in
some additional features.
We've made authentication
really, really easy.
We've added exponential back-off
for when you have any failures.
We've also made it so that you
can call that API synchronously
or asynchronously, depending on
whatever style of development
you are using.
So it's worth
checking these out.
So that brings me to the
close of this presentation.
And we've talked about these
four layers of development--
delegation, incorporation,
integration, and orchestration.
We've looked at them in the
context of various use cases
to build great solutions.
Everything I've talked about
today is actually available
on developers.google.com/maps.
It's where all of our
developer documentation lives.
And it links out to things like
our GitHub repository as well.
So please do check it out.
I want to thank you
for coming today.
And I'm open it up
for Q&A right now.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
If you do have a
question, if you can just
come to the microphone, we
have one right in the middle
here, that would the great.
AUDIENCE: Ankur, great talk.
You gave a lot of perspective
on functionalities
that you're offering
around basically
location-based services,
navigation, point location.
I mean, of course,
Google Maps also
has a very rich collection
of satellite imagery.
So have you been thinking
to take some of that data
out and put it through an API?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Just
the imagery itself?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just the
imagery itself, yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: We don't really
do that in a big way today.
The best-- in the Maps API
specifically, you can get maps
and you just change the
map style to an image.
But if you're looking for
map tiles specifically,
it's not something that
we make readily available
in this context here.
If you use some of the
custom styling stuff,
so it depends on what exactly
what your use case is.
The closest you could get is
that if you define a custom
style and turn off all the
labels and things for roads,
and then set the map
type to satellite,
you could get a
good satellite view.
But it really depends on
what you're doing there.
That might not be sufficient.
Well, I'm going to
be here on the side
if anybody has any
follow-up questions.
The other thing I
also should mention
is that tomorrow we've got
a number of great talks
on the Maps APIs.
We're going to be looking at
topics on specific verticals
like gaming.
We're going to be
looking at ride-sharing.
We have some interesting
talks on geolocation as well,
and location intelligence.
So I hope you're
able to join us.
And for those of you that
are watching on YouTube,
you can certainly
find those talks.
We'll be publishing them
on the Geo Developers Blog,
and on YouTube as well.
So thank you very
much, everybody.
I hope you enjoy the
rest of the conference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]